now water keeps dropping at Lake Mead
the park service and Bureau of Water
Reclamation introduced potential plans
last week to address the problem but as
Ryan Matthey shows us boaters took the
land today to have their say
it's up to them it's up to them it's up
to them no one's given us any straight
answers of how we can you know solve
this problem self-proclaimed boat
activist Vance Randall organized a swim
down the strip Friday night a rally of
around 30 boaters pulling their jet skis
and boats down the strip to protest the
potential of these launch ramps closing
there's thousands of people that use
that Lake there's millions that visit
that National Park every year and we
want this in the public Spotlight it
comes after a forum with the National
Park Service Bureau of Water Reclamation
and the public roughly 300 people heard
three plans they have to address
lowering levels one option to stop
maintaining five launch ramps meaning
marinas May close concessions would shut
down and utilities would be cut out we
sell boats in the desert it could mean
the livelihoods of those with businesses
on the lake like Bruce Nelson who runs a
boat rental company in the Lake Mead
Recreation Area without the recreation
area what do we do you know there's no
boating but will officials listen that's
yet to be determined but these boaters
here say with the Public's help their
Recreation could be saved there is
decision making going on public comment
period ends December 23rd and I just
couldn't imagine that the next
generation of kids don't have that
opportunity or the generation after that
that's not right
well that public comment uh the
organizer talking about there was to the
National Park Service the public has a
week from today to add their concerns
and opinions about how water is
ultimately conserved